yeah because we're running any of these
uh these guys in real life any of these
ready
so why does it affect you and a lot of
you know there's a theory out there
people got a lot of burners and they put
their own narratives out there and stuff
like that so you know yeah when I
learned about the Reddit the first thing
I'm like damn it's a lot of negativity
in there but then as time went on I'm
like okay so you run to Reddit and you
run the race I wasn't gonna say it and
you run the Reddit and you [__] work
here
but you know first when I was you know
I'm saying Adam was a moderator in there
Josh was a moderator in there uh they
said you're using moderator in there but
I talked to him last night he said I
actually wasn't a moderator I didn't do
anything I had no control over anything
but hey I don't know how this [__] is
ran but uh even if you're a moderator
then you're moderate moderators I mean
hey I mean God damn I mean and it was a
lot of crazy [__] being sent in this
group chat and I'm like what the [__]
who's saying that why are they saying
that like it was crazy but if you sit in
there and you like a now you gotta now
you got a whole nother profile doing
this [__] and making up these narratives
it gets really deep like I don't think I
have that much time on my hands and this
will actually do know this was the
turning point when it came down to it
I'm just gonna say
we started talking about topics that
were supposedly coming from the Reddit
and I remember when we was in New York
they lost it Adam everybody lost control
of it and when they lost control of it
oh it was a whole different Reddit so
you know they started asked questioning
us like wait a minute why are our woman
in these red is why are our kids in
these red is wires why is everything
attacking us but it's not attacking
y'all and it was like oh because you
know the rules are hey they're not on
the table they're not on the table but
we on the table like they be talking
about your families and [__] everything
yeah but it would never it and then
we're in we're bringing that to topics
that we're talking about online so it's
like all right cool but once it lost
control then it was like don't talk
about it no more what do you mean don't
talk about it no more we've been talking
about our lives for the last couple of
weeks and now since y'all can't control
the narrative no more y'all don't want
us to talk about it no more so that's
when you gotta you know put your
thinking cap on and say what the [__] is
really going on
obviously you and your girl have a
successful vlog
uh she's got a dope uh woman's uh yeah
shout out to Sorella
boutique.com yeah I mean so I I once
said Tupac was overrated in an interview
and like my wife got like 30 DMS from
Angry uh [__] yeah saying that
you white I'm a piece of [__] and
[Music]
how crazy is like Heather's DMS in terms
of like just these wild like fans Fringe
fans I mean I think they pretty cool I
mean they haven't like went over pretty
respectful yeah they're pretty
respectful right now they they they love
it man that's why you gotta laugh at
everything you know what I'm saying We
Gotta Laugh at ourselves and you you got
to put yourself out there because I'm
not a [__] that you can really like
bother and [__] like that like I'm a
[__] that can joke too like like if I
wasn't already like subconsciously I
don't think I'll probably be bothered
anyway you know what I'm saying I'm a
[__] that probably got over all of the
[__] you know I'm saying I have one arm
like I'm going through life with my arm
not working like and I'll let [__]
crack jokes on me [__] with me like all
the whole little [__] so none of that
[__] ever [__] bothers me if they
hitting there up and messing with her
like she don't even look at that [__]
anyway when she do she she got other
[__] you know I'm saying that she's
doing too man